well it turns out lots of Democrats are
friends with louis farrakhan congressman
Danny Davis of Illinois calls him an
outstanding human being said that to a
reporter from The Daily Caller smiled as
he did even Barack Obama has been
photographed meeting with Minister
Farrakhan but Mr Farrakhan has a
complicated history he has among other
things praised Adolf Hitler he said that
white people deserve to die he blames
the Jews for 9/11 but for some reason
nobody on Morning Joe seems to notice
why is that mark Stein is an author and
columnist he joins us to me
so mark to put this in context for you
The Dukes of Hazzard oh I don't know if
you're living this country then but it
was a pretty popular TV show 70s early
80s right it was pulled out of rotation
because there's a Confederate flag on a
car and that was considered from the
room from there oh yeah for the
sensibilities of American viewers
protect the children from that but then
Danny Davis is hanging out with a guy
who's saying you know the Jews are
bloodsuckers or whatever horrible thing
he's saying I'm like nobody cares cuz
why because he's on their team and the
left are very serious about this
Minister Farrakhan has said that instead
of boring on about what Hitler did to
the Jews the Jews should ask themselves
about what they did to Hitler to make
him so mad at them
that's how that's how he's formulated it
on multiple occasions the media and
powerful Democrats such as the deputy
chairman keith ellison looked the other
way they looked the other way since at
least the so-called Million Man March
when he went nuts and started talking on
the mouth that he was standing by the
Lincoln and Jefferson memorials and
Lincoln was the 16th president and
Jefferson was the third president and if
you add them up 16 and 3 makes 19 which
is the precise height of each of the
memorials and 19 the nine means there's
a pregnant womb and the one means
there's a secret that's going to be
uncovered he's a nut he's a nut now it's
not just that he hates Jews but he
claims to be
abducted Alan I believe at least two
occasions by aliens the first time he
was taken up into space to commune with
the spirit of Elijah Muhammad the
founder of the Nation of Islam and the
second time he was apparently abducted
by Jews who've got a UFO
there's Jews in space who knew so it
means that whenever Jared Kushner or
Tony Blair whoever solves the Middle
East peace process they're going to have
to get right on Minister favicons
rocketship and go up to Planet Xango and
sort out the squabbling Jews and Nation
of Islam guys up there in space it says
something absolutely appalling about the
Democrat Party that an obvious nut that
Obama that that even Maxine Waters that
keith Ellison that all these Democrats
are so scared of a lunatic that they
feel obliged to kiss up to him that's
useful I covered the Million Man March I
don't know any of that that's that's
amazing thank you see when imagine yeah
it's all in the double 16 plus 3 night
look he makes great calypso album so he
gave the fifties Annie Annie Annie can
carry off a red bow tie with a plum
which as you know Tucker is more
difficult than it looks so let's give
him that but it's embarrassing that this
nut is a power broker in the Democrat
Party and the media won't cover it
oh I wish you had an hour's talk with
this Mark Steyn thank you thanks a lot
Tucker